now to a royal on the Move Prince Harry
whose travels from Montecito California
to London made him a no-show for day one
of his historic UK phone hacking trial
Harry defied the Court's order leaving
the judge surprised the other legal team
accused him of wasting time he wasn't
available because he had been in La
celebrating his daughter lillibet's
second birthday party and I think it's
got off to a slightly awkward footing
for Prince Harry not being there he's
clearly irritated the judge but um is it
going to count as the black mark against
him and probably not we know through his
own words that Harry suffers with public
speaking he's known to have panic
attacks I think it's going to be a
pretty nerve-wracking experience for
Harry he's going to be asked very very
intense personal questions and he's
going to be asked to deliver proof this
was a fight worth fighting for the Duke
of Sussex is expected to take the stand
tomorrow which makes him the first Royal
to testify in high court in 132 years
he's suing mirror group newspapers
claiming they used illegal methods like
phone hacking to gain access to his
private life for stories which the
Publishers denied every relationship
that I had within a matter of weeks or
months was splattered all over the
newspapers we're told each hopped a
plane to London yesterday evening after
the birthday festivities but he's not
expected to see his father who has been
in Romania
foreign
there has been no conversation or
contact with his brother Prince William
or indeed with any other family members
and this is interesting no birthday
wishes for a little bit on any Royal
social media accounts and while a royal
Source tells E.T it has never been
protocol to share formal birthday wishes
for non-working members of the royal
family or their children we couldn't
help but notice the Royals did wish
littlebet a happy birthday last year and
congratulations are in order for
princess Eugenie she and husband Jack
Brooksbank just welcomed baby number two
Ernest George Ronnie on May 30th Eugenie
says their other son two-year-old August
is loving being a big brother already
Harry will have been among the first to
know about the Burtons in constant touch
with his cousin Eugenie she is one of
the few members of the royal family that
he speaks to on a regular basis I'm sure
if he's going to see anyone on this
fleeting visit to the UK and it will
probably be usually because he's going
to be very keen to meet the newest
addition to the Brooksbank family thank
you